gyeo storm failed to find sunny skies at
the box office over its opening weekend
pulling in just thirteen point three
million dollars domestic against a
reported budget of over one hundred and
twenty million dollars the disaster
thriller starring Gerard Butler as a
scientist a task for fixing satellites
protecting the world from the
catastrophic effects of climate change
was the latest in a string of big-budget
flops in 2017 knocked down by a rocky
production and a chilly reception from
critics yeah I think we've established
that still there's a lot more to what
went wrong with Geo storm than just the
obvious here are the real reasons why
geo storm are flopped at the box office
stormy skies geo storm took a long time
to make its way to theaters the movie
was initially sold to Warner Brothers in
2014 with a release date set for March
of 2016 but then the release was bumped
to October of 2016 then to January of
2017 and finally its eventual October of
2017 release a lot happened in the
interim to her tear storms chances of
success including some production
hurdles that drove up the cost and
generated bad word-of-mouth sources say
that debut director Dean Devlin's first
coat was unwatchable
and despite weeks of post-production and
the numerous other test screenings
things didn't appear to get any better
it's gotta be a glitch Devlin reportedly
became overwhelmed with the movie scale
and struggled to get it ready on time so
with the director's blessing the studio
brought some mega producer Jerry
Bruckheimer to oversee some fifteen
million dollar in reshoots under
director Danny cannon and a screenwriter
lead to color Greta's the resuits
removed some characters looking to
better tie together the film's already
existing VFX sequences in a way that
made sense although reports say that the
film tested much better after the edits
the added time and cost and the bad
press that came with it didn't help been
there done that
another problem with Geo storm is that
disaster movies are hardly new in recent
years there have been a bevy of similar
projects like San Andreas and the
Deepwater Horizon to name a few and
while some have seen success for being
in on their own jokes like the sharknado
series geo storm was trying to be
completely serious and Fay
stiffer competition as a result Devlin
himself helped to crowd the field
further when he sets up the Independence
Day sequel resurgence the lackluster
reception of which signified the
audience fatigue with disaster movies
something geo storms disappointing
performance seems to confirm bad buzz
the audience's disinterest in turning
alfred geo storm was reflected in the
movie's social media conversation and
unless noted that most of the
conversation about the film online was
negative with the viewers comparing it
to films like Armageddon and The Day
After Tomorrow audiences have been
getting more discerning recently about
reboots and remakes and even though geo
storm isn't officially based on a past
property the fact that the movie Jaws so
heavily and what's come before without
appearing to offer much that's new was
enough to keep audiences at home the
film was also largely maligned with
critics the studio decided not to screen
the film for reviewers and even held
back on offering Thursday night
screenings to protect the movies
potential for a Friday night haul
however nothing could prevent the movie
from eventually landing in the tough
hands of critics who absolutely tore it
apart Geo storm currently sits at a
dismal 11 percent rating on Rotten
Tomatoes with critics knockin the movie
for being big dumb and boring that
certainly couldn't have helped draw in
anyone who was on the fence about seeing
it in the first place marketing mayhem
micah ting plays a huge part in the
chances of a movie success but if geo
storms PR campaign telegraphed anything
to viewers it was the fact that the film
was an absolute mess this was mainly
shown in the huge difference in tone
between the film's first and second
trailers the first geo storm trailer was
a somber affair but getting quiet and
eerie before underlining some terrifying
and deadly climate related events the
second though was more akin to a
disaster comedy using the same clips but
with much more lighthearted music and
some quips from Gerard Butler and his
co-stars to make the typhoons and
earthquakes seem more like a fun romp
than a catastrophic world-ending event
sorry but that literally had to fly in
from outer space a loss of this probably
came about thanks to the movie's
extensive reshoots but the fact that the
two trailers were selling entirely
different films wasn't a good sign for a
potential audience too soon geo storm
was also the victim of some pretty bad
timing
arriving in theaters as a nation was
still reeling from the effects of three
devastating hurricanes as well as deadly
earthquakes in Mexico and the
catastrophic flooding around the globe
with so much disaster happening in real
life it's easy to understand why
audiences might want to avoid seeing it
on the big screen geo storms marketers
recognize this and pour'd posters
featuring the movies old tagline braved
the storm replacing them with a new
tagline reading control the weather
control the world however that doesn't
appear to have been enough as the movie
underperformed in regions that have been
hit by the Hurricanes while there's some
debate as to how much outside events
affect the movie's box-office
performance the fact that so much of the
movie's plot was reminiscent of
real-life tragedies likely kept at least
some viewers away thanks for watching
click the loop icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you're loved too
[Music]